Gregg Alba John lights out that's what I
was doing
guerrilla radio so lights out is a film
directed by a person who I don't know
who did it and starring people who I'm
not that familiar with David F Sandberg
who is not the David Sandberg who did
kung fury
alright so lights out here I'm just
gonna read you the ended the description
real fast to make it easy for you to
catch on when her little brother Martin
experiences the same events that once
tested her sanity
Rebecca played by Teresa pom Nina works
to unlock the truth behind the terror
which brings her face to face with an
entity that has attached to her mother
Sophie as an attachment to her mother
Sophie played by Maria Bello what makes
this movie cool is the plot of this is
something that I normally would have
seen in a horror movie that would have
been the reveal of a film if that makes
sense
besides a prologue with Billy Burke the
plot does set up that there's a swimmer
Maria Bello she lives with her son and
it was a young kid and then she's
friends with this ghost you know like it
says it up pretty early on this strange
entity of some yeah yeah we don't know
what it is exactly and basically we know
something [ __ ] up is happening and mom
is surprisingly comfortable yeah and
she's kind of supportive about this
thing yeah which is right off the bat
which to twist which make oh you [ __ ]
really maybe it's the sound version now
clunk Josie [ __ ] it's an [ __ ]
don't do it it's an [ __ ] out there
that's a smelly stinky shitty [ __ ]
Teresa Palmer plays Maria bellows
daughter she's moved out of the house
and establishes early on that when she
was young she's seeing the entity as
well so it's established him really
early on this movie that this entity has
been around for like many years now yeah
it's it's not a new thing to this to
this timeline or this which is really
cool cuz instead of like it being a
reveal after this entity is haunting
these people for a while then you find
out like oh it's really connected to
mom and wants the Maya yeah they know
we're gonna give you the information
pretty much up front and then we're
gonna let the movies just go well it's
cool cuz it sets itself up like a
monster movie but it doesn't play in
that way where it's like it's all about
finally getting to the and finding out
what the creature is and vanquishing it
it's like partway through the movie you
know Teresa Palmer walks in she's like
yeah I know what this thing this is a
movie that really is a character drama -
it's like to me this is like a more
funhouse version of the babadook you
have this you know creepy monster II
situation that's unfolding but it's
integral to all of the characters
involved it's fun too because it is
scared like it's a fun scary it's still
creepy still terror yet it's fun at the
same time as they're saying like they're
like babadook which are like like the
witch which are very unnerving that you
wouldn't sort of call fun horror films
you know lights out though has this
interesting blend of like great
characterization like Teressa Palmer is
a great lead actors in this yeah the kid
Gabriel Bateman he does a really good
job it's I love it when they get kid
actors who feel like real kids and like
the seem believable oh yeah yeah yeah
Maria Bello does a great job you know
what you understand why she's attached
you understand what her connection with
the ghost is well whatever it is a real
real human performance - cuz she plays
Alexander who is struggling and doesn't
quite know where she's at in her own
mind it's a performance that I feel like
could have been you know scenery knowing
and and while the movie does get big
sometimes I thought she played it really
well yeah cuz she still made sure to
connect with the other characters she
still made sure to develop a
relationship of talk in terms of Maria
Bella's performance because like what
you're saying a lot of times an actress
or an actor would get so caught up in
their one-man show good but it's like
you're really yeah taking the focus yeah
and there's just character place the
stress of Palmer's like love interest
like guess is what you would
characterize imagine Alexander - Persia
as right brett-brett man Bret stole the
show Bret's that character in the movie
with when you see him do like guys gonna
be some annoying what a douche
cool thing about this because I was like
I think this short is sort of a perfect
thing and then I saw the trailer I was
like backstory and like I don't know how
that's gonna work and like every few
minutes the movie didn't do what I
thought a typical one of these will do
it's like the first scene where you meet
Teresa Palmer and Brett that seem like
unfolds and they have a conversation and
they're just being characters yeah while
it's like and it seems like a real like
modern-day situation that people would
get it yeah like I said there are times
especially in the more dramatic scenes
between characters what the movie does
get a little big but it's okay because
everyone's really not even the guy who
plays even now Alexander diverges really
natural with his choices that's the only
one that no one was really going to this
movie to watch and he's the only one who
got a round of applause in the scene he
did anything about the thing that I
really liked about him is they made him
like a regular guy sort of to her like
when [ __ ] gets crazy like he responded
the way I think a regular guy would
respond like a regular yeah there are
choices that get made in horror movies
like this and this movie does a really
good job of backing them up with who
these people are you know and I think
this movie is a great horror film
because it does a lot of things where
they make things work that you've seen a
lot of horror movies try that don't work
examples or the explanations of the
entity who this is why they only show up
in the shadows and in the dark and why
they they can't be seen like it's great
explanations well yeah because they're
sneaky because they're not they're not
going this is why you should be afraid
it's more like this is why this thing is
important that's someone important to
you and instead of like it's you know
like a lot of times you're like oh this
person's gonna die this person's gonna
get killed at this moment or what if
yeah I feel like the director most like
along with James want creative producing
this film I imagine they they knew when
to just [ __ ] with the audience yeah and
when to lead them in a different
direction from because I know James long
can do that he will mislead you knowing
that a lot of people can be can predict
horror films now they'll mislead you
thinking that you know where it's gonna
go but it actually doesn't go that
direction and I wonder how much he was
directly involved because the thing is
like this doesn't feel like a James Bond
I feel like it has you know energies
approaches perhaps that he might use but
James want helped out yeah that's what I
wonder is there sir
shots aren't like that seems like a
James one thing I know and I bet that
would have been a cool environment for
him to go hey you know it would be cool
I'm sure it won't be like yeah that
would be [ __ ] cool let's do it and
and the entity isn't creepy yes she is a
creepy [ __ ] creature because and it's
not just about because it's it makes you
afraid of the dark I live alone and I
was pretty scared to keep the lights off
gonna be by a shadow at some point yeah
during your day and during that point if
you have to turn on a light you're gonna
think of it yeah there's like there's
clever [ __ ] effects clever moments of
wealth of light knowing when the shadows
are gonna like when she could appear in
a shadow
I love the prologue of the beginning
because I know this is based off a short
film but the prologue alone is its own
short film inspired by yeah yeah like
guys here you go leg right up the back
and like that's the cool thing about
this like this movie is really lucid and
it seems like everyone really thought
about it and had a good time thinking
about it and it's like I wish more
movies had just put the level of care
and effort into everything that I feel
like this film does cuz even like the
music is cool and it's not constant I
don't think it's shot terrifically
everyone's great in it the creatures
good like it's just everything is really
interesting and OnPoint and you know
even if it does get a little big for
itself sometimes like it's okay because
at that point it's that fun house vibe
because it is the perfect blend of sort
of a character centered horror story
with a scary-ass monster movie and a
certain amount of subtext about mental
illness and relations actually I want to
point it out because I think with you
know psychology it being something
that's way more present in our culture
today way more accepted in our culture
today of dealing with mental health
issues
I feel like horror movies are getting
even better at incorporated into their
films because all these characters are
like the alert most of them are family
related the relationships from the
actors are very strongly felt and
they're all dealing with trauma like
well yeah serious [ __ ] trauma and the
way they handle it and respond is like
ya know knowing the basics I know I'm
like that sounds like a reasonable
reaction to how things would go down
yeah and and and horror movies are the
perfect ground for you know at least
involving you know the fears of the
modern people or fears of any time
it's a good place for exploring that
stuff so when a movie takes time to
really do that you're like nice
you made an allegory that kind of works
because you see how it affects everybody
differently and you'll know when you see
it it's like even when you think about
Brett like there's a real and he was
like everyone's relationship to the
situation is different and that's just
nice to you all right was he nicest
surprise yeah I like that Phil Mader
like everyone's great what a prick was
the one I was like in weird very human
ways to find my expectations at every
point because like there is a moment
where they very much like they they make
you wonder about Brett yeah I really
enjoyed the way they wrote that
characters it was nice cuz it could have
been a throwaway character again like I
give it a four out of five poop scares
yeah four out of five poop scares like
that that's where you poop cuz you're
scared I might even go four and a half
I'm feeling good four point five poop
set it scares poop scares it's it's
subscribed and reject John Jerry
Facebook you know the stuff just let go
to the links in the description box give
it ten thousand Jerry's so I ratings
I'm good at ruining well I don't work I
don't work you've heard in an earlier